hey everybody I'm Gabe ho writer and no
ho sure I will not take you to church
because you never chip in for gas
welcome to hashtag news the Grammys were
on Sunday and they were as usual pretty
crazy like jay-z great.i mean cos jay-z
was probably there right probably he was
definitely there did you even watch okay
fine gabe hill writer don't really care
about the Grammys but celebrity news
correspondent Gabriel Hilton does so
let's try this the gram grams as we all
know are really just a way for tributes
to dress up in their crazy outfits to
get gifts from their sponsors let's take
a look at some of the craziest outfits
on the red carpet this year SIA showed
up in this wig which explains why she
couldn't tell where the audience was
during her performance am i right Kim
Kardashian forgot to wear a dress and
showed up in her bathrobe here's her
realizing that Briana came as a worn-out
shower loofah Charli XCX got a job as a
caterer I don't know how much longer I
can do this character katy perry- eyes
shut rubes another brew brothers iggy
azalea had an ex head berlin his wife
showed up ready to run a 5k formal
everyone's unstable aunt Madonna who the
internet had to remind his 56 years old
showed up wearing a weird Matador
costume and a device that I think is
designed to push up the food a my
stomach but by far the worst dress that
this year's grammys was this bald guy
who showed up in a lanyard where do you
think you are a cardboard convention
boom z snap finger on the butt cuz it's
hot sizzle sound see I'm done also as
i'm sure you all saw kanye pulled a
kanye and everyone freaked out that
kanye is still the same Kanye as the
last time Kanye Kanye stopped inviting
him pentatonix won their first Grammy
despite saying that they recorded it in
the bedroom closet and film it in the
kitchen I do the same thing so I get
someone a matter of time until Gabe
reads fan mail takes home an oscar hot
shoot kristen wiig blew everyone away
with her amazing performance during
Sia's song chandelier and what was even
more impressive is that she did it
without seeing even knowing she was
there you already made a see a Jew also
her name doesn't even make sense what
are you talking about she can't see a
thing oh my god you know and you know
what else I don't get I'm all about
Thanks bout that bass no treble you need
the trouble you're currently saying that
phrase in the travel section of the sug
is this what you want no I didn't think
so and that's it for hashtag news like
this video if you think Katy Perry's
performance could have used a little
more left shark subscribe for more sass
coverage from Gabriel Hilton comment on
who you think should have won at the
Grammys and follow us on twitter at new
rock stars for the latest news on
youtubers minors and whoever else you
kids are into I've been [ __ ] writer
since birth and remember dance like
nobody's watching unless somebody is
watching and then sit down quick